[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain a drama film called room
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
24 year old joy lives in a tiny room
with her son jack the room has a toilet
and bath in one corner and a makeshift
kitchen in the other the mother and son
share a single bed because of the
limited space it has only a skylight
that works as a window and the door
needs a passcode to be opened jack has
never in his life been outside of the
room his mother joy was abducted by a
man seven years ago who has been holding
her captive in the same room ever since
jack is the result of the sexual abuse
joy had to go through because of the
abductor the only form of entertainment
the kid has is an old tv which he thinks
is a magic box he believes that people
inside the tv are aliens who live on
another planet with trees and animals
the film begins with jack waking up and
saying hi to the inanimate objects
around the room like the chair the
wardrobe the sink and so on since he has
only seen two people in his life he has
made friends with the objects around the
room the kid has no concept of space and
thinks that the room is all that exists
to avoid explaining the harsh truth of
his life joy has never told him about
the outside world the two have named the
abductor old nick he comes to joy every
night and assaults her sexually after
seven years of torture she has gotten
used to it he also brings them necessary
groceries and buys them clothes once in
a while jack is excited because today is
his fifth birthday his mother makes him
a cake with whatever materials they have
jack is stoked about getting something
he has only ever seen on tv but is
disappointed to see the cake has no
candles he demands that joy should have
asked old nick for candles for their
sunday treat joy claims that she can
only ask him for necessary goods when it
turns dark she makes jack sleep inside a
tiny cupboard as usual she does this so
the kid won't have to witness old nick
assaulting her when the abductor enters
the room jack watches him through the
slats of the cupboard he is terrified of
going out because he can tell the man
hurts his mother the following day as
joy is eating breakfast a bad tooth
falls out of her mouth she hands it to
her son who keeps it in his mouth ew
they have breakfast which is only a
piece of toast the kid wishes to eat
something else but joy doesn't respond
knowing that this is all she can provide
him when jack wakes up the next morning
he is overjoyed to see a brand new toy
car on the table old nick has brought it
for him as a present for his birthday
jack believes that old nick is a
magician who can bring stuff out of the
tv he plays with the car for the entire
day around the room for an hour or so
the two scream at the ceiling hoping to
catch someone's attention but as usual
nothing happens later while talking jack
mentions his imaginary pet dog lucky joy
tells him that lucky isn't real making
him upset when joy is distracted jack
sees a mouse on the floor for the first
time in his life he tries to touch it
but joy notices and chases it away he is
sad because the mouse was the only
animal he has ever seen that night while
making dinner joy accidentally leaves
the toaster oven on and it catches fire
she quickly turns it off and tries to
wave off the smell hoping old nick won't
notice however when he comes around at
night he smells the burnt cheese
instantly he gets annoyed and calls her
names when she snaps back with a snarky
comment he gets violently angry and
almost hits her it turns out he was laid
off from work six months ago and can
hardly provide for the three of them
poor jack tries to ignore the
conversation but accidentally makes a
noise old nick notices and tries to open
the cupboard to see him to keep him from
talking to her son joy invites him to
the bed later that night jack sneaks out
of his cupboard and tiptoes over to the
two of them old neck happens to be awake
and sees the kid he lunges for jack but
joy throws herself on top of him
preventing him from touching her son an
enraged nick threatens to kill her and
storms off leaving a crying jack behind
joy consoles him as he sobs in her arms
and apologizes for coming out of the
cupboard the next morning the room is
suspiciously cold joy notices that their
heater is turned off which means old
nick must have cut off the power supply
to the shed joy knows that they cannot
survive in the cold for long moreover
with the shortage of money she is afraid
nick will starve them to death so she
sits jack down and explains to him that
they are being held in a shed by a bad
person she tells him that she was only
17 when old nick asked her to help him
with his sick dog he fooled her and
kidnapped her in the shed before that
she used to live with jack's
grandparents in a house that had a
hammock the kid refuses to believe her
and declares that trees houses and
hammocks only exist on tv although jack
is stubborn joy keeps on telling him
things about the outside world she even
shows him a dried leaf that has fallen
on the skylight but the kid insists the
leaves are green so she must be lying
the next day while watching tv he asks
her if trees and people are real joy
calmly explains to him how the real
world works finally making him believe
her not wasting much time she devises a
plan to escape she boils water and uses
it to make it look like jack has a fever
she even forces herself to vomit and
spreads it around the pillow to make him
smell bad the kid cries and claims he
doesn't want to do it joy doesn't enjoy
seeing him crying but she has no other
way to escape when old nick arrives that
night she tells him that the cold has
made jack sick nick touches his forehead
which is burning because of the hot
water he claims that he will bring
antibiotics tomorrow and leaves joy is
disappointed because she had thought he
would take jack to the hospital where
the kid would have a chance to escape
the following day she thinks of a new
plan she asks jack to pretend to be dead
and rolls him up in a rug she trains him
to unroll himself and run for help the
kid is told he will be taken outside by
old nick where he will meet real people
who he has to ask for help he is scared
but agrees to do it when old nick
arrives a while later joy has already
wrapped up jack inside the rug and is
pretending to cry she claims that he
died during the night and blames old
nick for his death nick panics and
quickly brings the kid out still rolled
up in the rug he puts him onto the back
of a pickup truck and drives off from
inside the rug jack feels the truck
driving he unravels the rug and is
mesmerized to see the full view of the
sky for the first time when the truck
slows down he carefully jumps out of it
old nick notices and stops the truck but
by then jack has already met a man
walking his dog old nick tries to bring
jack back to the vehicle but the man
finds it suspicious and threatens to
call the police old nick drives away
after leaving the kid lying on the
ground jack stays there until he is
rescued by the police he tells them
about his mother and shows them the
tooth he has of hers when he mentions
that they live in a shed that they
aren't allowed to leave the police
realize the severity of the situation
they quickly call for backup and start
searching for the shed only a few hours
later they rescue joy who is fortunately
safe she reunites with her son and
praises him for his work the two hug
celebrating their freedom after being
captured for seven years when jack wakes
up the next day he finds himself in a
bed in a hospital room he looks outside
the window still unable to believe that
the outside world is real joy and him
take a bath in a shower for the first
time jack is scared to go under running
water but eventually gets used to it the
doctors perform several tests on them
and declare them healthy they are
recommended to wear a lot of sunscreen
since they were hardly exposed to
sunlight in captivity jack is also told
to wear sunglasses if the world seems
too bright the kid is nervous to talk to
the doctor so he quietly whispers to joy
if he wants to say something joy's
parents nancy and robert finally arrive
at the hospital and embrace their
long-lost daughter in a tight hug they
had accepted she was never going to
return after suddenly disappearing one
day joy is told that her parents have
divorced and her mother is now dating a
man named leo following that joy and
jack are taken home where a crowd of
people and reporters have gathered to
witness the return
jack needs help to walk down the stairs
because he is not used to it he meets
leo who is delighted to see both of them
after they are settled nancy comments
that they should cut jack's hair but the
kid quietly whispers that his strength
is in his hair at dinner the family
enjoys a nutritious meal that is foreign
to jack he eats ice cream for the first
time and experiences a brain freeze
maybe life was better in the room joy
notices that her father hasn't talked to
jack at all she realizes that he is not
comfortable with jack being his
grandchild because he was the product of
her being sexually assaulted enraged
that he is not willing to accept her son
she gets into an argument with him and
storms off to her room with jack the
following day joy shows jack a picture
of her and her high school friends she
is clearly annoyed at the fact that
their lives turned out to be nice while
she was rotting in that hell of a room
jack has a hard time adjusting to the
new life he never leaves his mother's
side and doesn't talk to anyone else leo
makes the kid comfortable and talks to
him like a father which helps him a lot
joy falls deep into depression after
failing to be happy even after getting
out of captivity she forces jack to play
even when he refuses to and gets into a
huge argument with her mother some days
later their family's lawyer informs them
that they will need money for the
upcoming trial and the easiest way to
get some is to do a prime time interview
a journalist shows up at the house to
interview joy she asks her intrusive
questions about self-harm and her
relationship with the captor making her
feel worse than she already did at one
point in the interview joy is asked why
she didn't beg the abductor to leave
jack in an orphanage implying that she
was selfish the interviewer has upset
her so much that she sinks into
depression the next morning jack walks
to the bathroom and is horrified to see
his mother laying on the ground but she
is soon saved by the paramedics while
joy is admitted to the hospital jack is
left alone with nancy and leo with time
he begins opening up to them and gets
used to being around people leo brings
his dog home which excites jack who
still remembers his imaginary dog lucky
one day jack tells nancy he wants to cut
his hair and send it to joy because she
needs his strength more than he does
nancy happily does as he says and gives
the boy a neat haircut at the end of it
the kid tells her that he loves her
nancy is overwhelmed and hardly manages
to whisper back i love you too
that day a neighbor's kid calls jack out
to play he makes a friend for the first
time in his life and plays with him in
the backyard at the same time joy
returns home and smiles watching him
play when the mother and the son meet
she claims that his hair helped her get
well quickly as time passes jack
experiences several things with his
mother they go to different restaurants
parks and places that they didn't get to
visit for all those years they also hang
a hammock at the house that jack has
always wanted to play in as the two are
swinging in it jack asks to visit the
room joy is shocked by the request but
she agrees to take him for a visit when
jack returns to the place he comments
that it is shrunk since they were last
here because he remembers it being
bigger
before leaving he wishes the objects in
the room a goodbye like he used to wish
them while in captivity
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching